[Music]
john cena dishes on wedding plans with
fiance and Nikki Bella I just want to
make sure that it's a it's a good day
et spoke with the newly engaged couple
at the premiere of his new Amazon
Studios film the wall I just want you
know we've we've made our lives very
public and and I think the world knows
that it's been a lot to just get to that
proposed a moment and I really want I
wanted to be as happy as she was at that
moment I couldn't I had to retell her
things that I told her on that day
because she was so happy she couldn't
process it as long as we have that
happiness on on that day I think I'm
good very likely not really not gonna be
in particular about the sconces or you
know the silverware this one I want that
smile John also revealed how Nikki
adorably surprised him for his 40th
birthday she did works dick absolutely
awesome she orchestrated a surprise
party for him back friends from high
school friends from college co-workers
in my entire family and I'm a very tough
person to surprise and initially I was
angry that I had been happy I've been
surprised but then it sunk in that all
these people came to this event in in a
very small town
it was a wonderful night and I'm the
heels of something special between us
she supplied me with another surprise
another great moment that I was going to
the rest of my life
[Music]
you